This message is brought to you by Deadpool
See, when you make a sequel,
you have to double down on your promotions,
or you just get buried
Welcome back everyeone, Maximum effort. It's a busy week for Deadpool.
The new movie is going to be taking over the planet
really soon.
We've got several core X-Men
fantastic Four coming back.
Probably a couple other surprise
deep cuts from the Fox Marvel movies, too.
And there's been a lot of talk about Deadpool
saving the Marvel Universe,
like basically saving people's interest
in Marvel movies just in general, and in real life.
Kevin Feige is kind of using the Deadpool movie
to do something like that.
But what he's really doing in the context of the movie
is essentially destroying the Marvel Universe.
Deadpool, saving the MCU, or the Marvel Multiverse,
however you want to think about it. Bye.
Burning it to the ground.
saving the thing that matters most by killing it.
there's been a lot of theories about this.
I know there's lots of questions.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
Next week is the Super Bowl.
They'll be releasing the Deadpool three trailer.
They'll probably be a bunch of other
related Deadpool videos that Hugh Jackman
and Ryan Reynolds will release
that aren't really trailers,
but they're like funny promotions they posted before
Of course I will do videos for whatever
they wind up releasing in my mind, that's
actually better than actual trailers because they don't
actually have to spoil plot points from the movie.
I'm really, really busy doing some stuff.
And if I bet your bottom dollar that.
Yeah. Yeah.
Don't give him too much attention.
That's why I can't be done Some.
There'll be some Happy birthday.
I have a great two dogs out.
Who wrote them out?
No one knows. No one ever saw that mystery.
All right. okay.
all the Deadpool
marketing campaigns are peak amongst Marvel movies.
In fact, inside the MCU, if you're just talking about
non Deadpool Marvel movies,
probably the best press tour that they've ever done
was for Captain America Civil War.
With all the non trailer promos
they released Just imagine
Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman
doing stuff like that for the next six months or so.
well, we just got a new synopsis for the movie
that was released by Marvel Japan.
And it translated, it reads, The irresponsible hero
Deadpool will change the history of the MCU
with Wolverine, that's meant to be a reference
to Deadpool and Wolverine,
essentially destroying the Marvel Universe,
the Marvel multiverse
just in general
as you've known it since Iron Man one Marvel Phase one.
what they've also been calling the sacred timeline
before the events of the Loki series,
when Loki also started making changes
to the way the multiverse worked with his tree.
In all the timelines, the movie is loosely adapting
from Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe
and the Secret Wars comics
using a lot of the characters from the Loki series
in Twist that it's set up to all as a way
to bring back a lot of the Fox X-Men, Fantastic
Four movie actors, maybe some surprise characters
from other Fox Marvel movies and even a few Sony
Spider-Man movies to in, in the way Deadpool movies
always clowned on all other Marvel movies.
They'll be using the multiverse trope in the film
to clown all the recent Marvel
Multiverse movies like Doctor Strange,
Multiverse of Madness, Ant-Man, the WASP, Quantumania,
any other Multiverse related movie
you've seen the last couple of years?
there's been a lot of complaints.
People saying that there's audience fatigue
with the whole multiverse
trope, like,
can we just get back to the single version of Earth?
And that's kind of what the Deadpool movie is
meant to be inside the MCU,
sort of like the tipping point
where they're starting to move back in that direction
Deadpool just in general is meant to be the mouthpiece
of the fandom, which is why he often breaks
the fourth wall talking to the audience themselves,
calling out tropes, things that just did not work.
Before he became part of the MCU with the Fox
Disney bio, he did the same thing,
but just for the X-Men movies,
calling out all their confusing recasting
with the younger cast coming along at the time
they filmed that joke, it specifically was not intended
to play into Loki's timelines in the multiverse,
but it just worked out perfectly after the fact.
Now, you can say his reference to messing
with all the timelines in Deadpool one and Deadpool
two, cleaning up the timelines are a reference
to the same timelines from the Loki series.
use it to picture Deadpool
just hopping around all of the different timelines
that Loki is trying to keep under control in a big
part of the movie is meant to clown on the fact
that Disney in real life
did buy Fox and Marvel is slowly recasting
all of the old Fox Marvel actors, the X-Men,
the Fantastic Four,
with the new MCU versions of the movies
coming in the next couple of years.
with the holidays thought to be fun.
A PG 13. It's a family movie. Also money. Also Disney.
So according to one of their official synopsis
for the movie, Deadpool
actually begins
the movie having retired from being a superhero,
which is also a bit of a joke about how Marvel is done
with all of the Fox Marvel movies.
Like, Yeah, that was an old era.
We're going to push that off to the side
and do our new stuff.
So Deadpool doesn't feel the need to be a superhero
anymore, at least at the beginning of things.
and apparently he's working as a used car salesman
just to earn money until he's
thrown back through the multiverse and begins
to search for the perfect version of Wolverine
until he finds Hugh Jackman's Wolverine from a universe
where all of the X-Men and the Fantastic Four are way
more comic book accurate, closer
to what you see during X-Men, the Animated series.
in that's also meant to clown on the fact that Hugh
Jackman is the perfect version of Wolverine
in real life.
And Kevin Feige will never be able to cast
a better actor than his version.
I think we all expected it, but this just confirms
the Deadpool movie is also making fun of Kevin Feige
and Marvel in real life as well.
But he's kind of in on the joke.
Like they made a Kevin Feige
reference in the first Deadpool movie with the pizza.
Kevin Feige
actually got his start
producing on the original Bryan Singer X-Men movie.
Like he and Hugh Jackman go way, way back movie
that we think of all the Fox
X-Men movies is sort of like a different era of Marvel
just in general.
Kevin Feige was a core part of that era too.
It's just that
he wasn't as on camera during that period.
fun. Fact two There's even a deleted scene cameo
that Kevin Feige
has in the original X-Men movies
as part of the Weapon X program.
He's the person that pulls Wolverine's
adamantium claws out of an oven.
But he said that people will never,
never see that deleted scene.
Apparently if any of you hackers out there are actually
huge Marvel fans, please get on that case.
this is why Kevin Feige specifically using Deadpool
three as a sort of a tribute to all those classic X-Men
movies, Fantastic Four movies, other Fox Marvel movies,
because they were part of that pre MCU era.
And of course, they do want to recast the new movies,
but it's not like Kevin Feige
actually hates
any of these original X-Men actors.
really good example of this recasting stuff
as we've been talking about the new Fantastic
Four movie cast for a couple years at this point,
like who's going to be in this new movie,
even though it kind of
looks like we've found out who that's going to be.
is the same situation with the new X-Men
reboot movie Marvel is making right now.
We'll get a director for that in a script by next year
and will probably right up
releasing it around
2026, 27, around the time Avengers five is coming out.
end, in that movie, most of the X-Men
will be totally new actors playing the characters.
There are a couple exceptions to this,
like Ryan Reynolds will continue to play Deadpool,
even though he's joking about becoming
too old to do a lot of the stunts.
Hugh Jackman will continue to play that Wolverine
through secret wars.
Some of the other classic X-Men
will come back in secret wars for cameos.
but one of the other big reasons,
probably the biggest reason Deadpool
is ultimately going to destroy the Marvel Universe
or multiverse is Kevin Feige is using him in the movie
as a sort of soft reboot tool that will allow Marvel
to reboot the MCU just in general.
After secret Wars.
so they can recast any big characters or actors
that they need to recast as the description of Deadpool
three states.
They'll change things so that history was different.
In all,
the characters have always existed on the same Earth
Avengers or X-Men, Mutants, Fantastic Four, everybody
And for most of the characters,
they probably won't remember that there was a reboot
and they won't think it's weird that they, like
mutants, have been running around this whole time
all over the planet and are being persecuted
by governments because they're so powerful.
Because it wouldn't be an X-Men movie
if they weren't being persecuted.
one of the biggest problems
Marvel's run into the last several years with them
getting all the characters back
is that they have all these huge characters
that they didn't have access
to previously, and Kevin Feige.
Going back to Marvel, Phase one
always wanted to be able to tell these larger stories
with all the toys in the toy box, so to speak,
but could not blame all the lawyers for that.
best example of this is the deleted post-credits scene
from that first Iron Man movie.
So we're talking about the very first MCU movie.
He tried to set up the concept of Avengers, X-Men,
Spider-Man, all being on the main MCU, Earth,
the whole reason why they filmed that scene
in the first place then didn't wind up using it
in the final version of the movie is Kevin Feige
wanted Spider-Man in the X-Men
to be in that first Avengers movie,
but at the time, as you would expect, this is still
when Fox was ramping up with the X-Men movies.
Hugh Jackman was about to hit
his peak popularity as Wolverine.
They were about to start making the Wolverine
Origins movie.
They also had that bad version
of Ryan Reynolds Deadpool in that two,
they wouldn't let Marvel borrow
any of the X-Men characters for cameos at the time.
Kevin Feige even tells the story
about how he tried to get a cameo scene
from Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
in the very first Captain America movie.
When he rescues the Howling Commandos.
he wouldn't have become Wolverine.
Yet you didn't get the adamantium skeleton
until later in the timeline.
But he still has mutant healing factor in the bone
claws in it wasn't any better on Sony side of things
either like Sony would not let Spider-Man cameo
in any of the MCU Marvel movies at the time.
It would have been Tobey Maguire Spider-Man
in that first Avengers movie.
Sony and Fox separately also tried to have a crossover
between Wolverine and Spider-Man in early days
during that first Spider-Man movie,
he would have met him on the street, but on the day
they were going to film the cameo scene,
even though the lawyers had agreed to it,
they couldn't get the Wolverine suit in.
For whatever reason,
they didn't want to film the scene without the suit.
so the cameo just wound up
hitting the cutting room floor.
So you have all these issues with Marvel
being able to tell these types of stories
that they want to tell with these characters together
in the same universe, on the same earth.
Hugh Jackman even predicted this happening back
when they were making the Wolverine movie
So cut to present day, you have all the characters
in the toybox with no big problems.
You can cross over anybody you want to cross over,
But you have to explain how they all wind up together
because they're all coming
from different universes now.
So the easy solution is to basically have Deadpool
destroy the Marvel Universe
and use it as a soft reboot.
That's where Deadpool Secret Wars come in.
Basically during Deadpool three.
The early theory is that this translates
to Deadpool's actions messing with the multiverse,
all the timelines causing more and more incursions,
causing the multiverse to slowly be destroyed
even faster in the movie will directly set up Avengers
secret wars where the TVA gets involved.
They try to mitigate the disaster
by saving as many people from different universes
as possible, by putting them on the void plan,
which in the MCU will probably be their version
of battle world from the comics
and even though longtime comic book fans of secret wars
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe will be following
along all those references to the original stories
they're adapting the casual audience will just see that
Marvel is effectively collapsing,
destroying the Marvel Universe, and slowly
rebooting and resetting things.
going back to that original Deadpool jokes.
So many timelines, so confusing.
How do you fix this problem?
All the production issues that marvel,
How do you completely explain and fix everything?
Just a soft reboot
and let Deadpool have his fun in destroy
everything, burn it to the ground,
then rebuild it the way that it needs to be rebuilt.
then after secret wars,
when they do rebuild the multiverse, you can explain
how everybody's been on the same earth this whole time
and just go forward in the movies with that
so you don't have to come up with a super
complicated explanation for why The Avengers
are fighting the X-Men all of a sudden
in why Wolverine is fighting Hulk to the death.
All of a sudden.
everybody let me know in the comments if Deadpool is
slowly going to be burning the multiverse to the ground
or like hastening its destruction
and they're going to soft reboot after secret wars,
what do you want
the movies to look like going forward after that?
Because it does look like they're going to be focusing
way more on brand new stuff.
Hence X-Men Mutant related stuff, fantastic force stuff
for like the next ten years of Marvel.
big reminder.
We have the Deadpool
three trailer coming this next week.
Be sure to enable alerts for my channel so
you don't miss that.
There's a bunch of other big Super Bowl trailers.
I'll try to do videos
for all the really, really big stuff.
we'll also probably get a trailer video for the X-Men
97 episodes in the next couple of weeks
to Everybody click here
for all those brand new Deadpool three teaser trailers
and click here to learn about Marvel's New Iron Fist.
Thank you so much for watching and maximum effort!